my next guest is a hilarious stand-up
comedian and one of the newest writers
on conan please welcome
skyler higley schuyler thank you for
being here man thank you for having me
what's it like joining mid pandemic
because if you're in a writer's room
it's essentially a lot of
chemistry and you have to do the
weirdest thing imaginable which is this
cold zoom meeting and technical errors
it took i would say maybe slightly
longer than
um usual but i think it's fine now like
coming into a
new writing staff i think always the
problem is in a new group of people
it's always like when do i make the joke
and the thing about
zoom is if you try to make a joke at the
same time as somebody else
it's just nobody's gonna hear anything
either of you said
so that was kind of like the first big
hurdle of like
when do i even talk because
everybody is already on the same page
about things
i know you mean other than that like
being in the room
is one of the things i enjoy the most
about my day because
a lot of it on it's particularly with
the conan staff everybody's friends
a lot of it's just like kind of
bullshitting a lot uh the same thing
that andy was talking about
being very mean to each other or not
each other but being mean about things
and making jokes that are like yeah
we're all just like hanging out and then
like a half hour or more into the
meeting
then matt o'brien will be like okay
let's read some pitches
and you know it's like we've been just
doing nothing for
a while yeah but it is a great way to go
in though and
you're talking like a human being and
not just going cold and have to read
an incredibly dumb sketch right this is
dr
fart helicopter right and god forbid
conan joins the zoom then we're just
like
not even gonna get to any then it's just
like you know conan bits
and then we just are like hanging out
with him and having fun so it's just
like
it the most fun i think someone could
probably have
uh working in the time that we're
working
so you started as a stand-up in chicago
and is this true you grew up
mormon i did um and it was
a thing that like i talk about it in
stand-up a lot
it was a thing that i didn't even think
was weird
or like something that people didn't
relate to until i was about a year in
and then everybody's like you grew up
mormon that's like kind of
crazy and i was like oh is it and
they're like yeah nobody's mormon
except for if you grew up in utah where
i grew up then everybody's mormon and
i'm like
yeah it's it's normal for like everybody
in the same state to be
like almost the same religion right and
everybody else is like no
no that is that is a utah thing that is
uh
yeah because it's a very specific one
they get a lot of hate just because
it's so new yeah another 100 years
where until it's acceptable or maybe
just get out of utah maybe
tour i mean yeah that was that was my
thing because i just had to like get out
because
i just i always felt out of place in in
utah and i didn't like
i just didn't you know i i wasn't the
same as everybody else
i like it's a state that's like what
99.99 white it's like
me and the utah jazz are the only black
people there
right and i moved to chicago and it
like it's it was just much more like uh
i became myself
i think through like comedy you know i
grew up very religious there's a
back part of my mind where i'm like you
know what you make a killing
because if you become a church comic
okay
um that's something that i had
considered because like
i remember when i was gonna go into
comedy um my mom
uh like told my family and
immediately my grandma got me this dvd
that was like um
like to say like hey if you're gonna do
comedy you know don't have to like
curse and stuff you could be like one of
these like
best mormon comedians yes you had this
like specific dvd that i
never watched by the way that um
comedy yeah it was like mormon comedy
that was like
you ever be it church and
you know xyz you take the sacrament and
then you feel connected to
like i don't know how that could be
funny bring them young material but they
make a
killing just imagine being like you're
you're killing it
you're killing it for the lord so you
think god is happy with you the whole
time
yeah and then you get like a giant check
10 of which you give back to the church
but that's okay like
i mean that's got to be a pretty good
living you know what i've convinced
myself i'm going to go do church comedy
now
wow what religion did you grow up uh my
parents made up their own thing
they did they took a little bit of yeah
catholicism
and uh made up their own thing and um
tried to take that out to the roads we
were missionaries for that and it did
not work out
we had zero followers how long were you
a missionary for
uh maybe ten years a long time right
yeah but not like
like help people and like staying with
them and and
and uh you know we're gonna build a
school we were just like uh aggressive
street preachers we'd go
to a concert outside of a utah jazz game
or something and just be screaming at
people
oh my god you're like yeah
yeah there's a lot of pressure in
mormonism
like when you turn uh 18 to like
it's like men like go on missions for
like
two years where like that's your whole
thing everybody's seen the book of
mormon musical they know how this works
yeah
i was so afraid of like doing that
because like by that time i was like
i'm not gonna be i can't commit to
something like that for like two years
and
just do this like one thing so you guys
going like 10 years and then not even
being like
knock knock hi how you doing do we want
to talk about this guy but like
screaming at people
that's nuts man yeah it's a lot so
people are you nervous to stand up like
no as long as i'm not telling
older women that they're going to hell
like all right that was probably the
walmart that gave you the confidence to
be like
yeah if i yeah if i bomb
it's like you know i can bob it's
no worse than the things that i've said
to people on the street
yeah but i think uh missionaries and
religious people have
insulated themselves so you can't pop so
if anyone persecutes you
they don't get it they're not saved i
think comedians need that
we need a way to insulate ourselves
because now if you don't do well
or someone hates you it's like they hate
me yeah
well that's what i got that's what i do
is like if i get off stage and i bombed
them like they didn't get it
they don't get any jokes they all you
know i am god
make it about them yeah i think the only
way to
truly navigate um comedy and not like be
uh anxious and depressed all the time is
you're either like anxious
and like self-hating like me or you
are just a huge like narcissist and you
think like everything you do is perfect
and um i mean like i go back and forth
i wish i had more of the second one just
to be like i see the clips that people
release and i see the stuff they put out
i'm like
i wish i had that confidence can you
imagine the
the pathology involved to like actually
comment something negative on
of like something else that somebody
made like who are you what do you do
if there are any negative comments on
this i will personally fight each and
every negative comment i will find now
you're inviting them but that's fine
because that's just engagement and it's
going to boost us in the algorithm
that's right negativity rises to the top
it starts the conversation so people are
like oh something because there's
nothing interesting about
kill that question good so people want i
think we should start a feud
between us it should be a huge blow up
so we have it in the thumbnail
do you want to just start just like some
some beef over some sort of
like just some kind of public rivalry
yeah it's gonna be great for our brands
i'm gonna go
hard hardcore into anti-masking
you can be the you'll be the fan
favorite
i i'll be the villain and i'll just say
i i won't even go anti-mask they say you
wear two masks now i'm just going to be
going hard until like i only wear one
mask and that can be our split
see that's the stance that's the nuance
dance is the one masked guy this guy
sells out pc culture wants him to wear
two masks
it is gross that's what that's what
generates any sort of
heat success is just the negativity
and i'm 100 down to play the game i
think we'll
we'll get into a fight about uh joke
theft but it's going to be the worst
joke right i stole from you so just
incredibly corny yeah he stole my thing
about how like
sometimes you take an edible and then
you're suddenly like
so high out of nowhere that was my
comedy market
of i took an edible and then something
it's like every time i hear the stories
i'm like you're an adult
you took an edible plane what did you
think was gonna happen
right it was a story you took an edible
and nothing happened or or the whole
like
i have worked with or around kids and
you know what
i don't like them it's like great like
we
hey like we know hey i love it
okay well we have a very bright future i
like this i can't wait to see you again
and perform at a real show
i know uh you're killing it on the show
everyone loves you around there so
hang in there keep keep doing your thing
yeah man thank you so much for having me
of course skylar higley everyone